Voiceover: What I've
drawn right here is an
inverted oil futures curve.
So if the futures curve looks
like this, it just means that it's
more expensive to buy oil
today than to agree to buy
oil at some future date,
two months from now,
four months from now or
eight months from now.
There's a couple of reasons
why this might happen.
The most common reason
might just be there might be
some type of shortage
right now for whatever
reason, maybe ... maybe there's
a war going on and all of a
sudden we need a lot more
fuel to support all of the
crazy machinery and all of
that or maybe some oil got
destroyed, maybe some oil
wells are burning. Who knows?
There might be some type
of shortage, so people are
willing to pay a premium
for oil right now.
The other reason why you
might have an inverted oils
future curve and this will
actually gel a little bit more
with kind of what we're going
to talk about in this video
is that people expect the price
of oil in the future to not
be that different than the
price of oil today. If you were
to go out there and survey
everyone who might be a seller
or buyer of oil in the
world, which is obviously not
possible, but if you were to ask them,
"What is the expected price
of oil in eight months?",
they might say, "Hey, okay we
might even have a little shortage
"right now, but we expect
the price of oil to be $100."
and so you might say, "Wait.
If everyone expects ...
"If everyone expects the
price of oil to be $100,"
"why are there some people
in the futures markets today"
"who are agreeing to
sell the oil for $50?"
"They're agreeing to sell it
below the expected price."
And the reason why they
might be willing to, maybe
their oil producers and oil
is such a volatile price and
because they are dependent
on oil revenues to support
the people who live in that
country or whatever else.
They're essentially, in order
to guarantee the price and
and not be susceptible to the
volatility, they're willing to
sell it at a discount, to this
theoretical expected price.
So either way, this could lead
to an inverted futures curve.
Now, in kind of common lingo
when people see an inverted
futures curve like this,
they'll often use the word
"backwardation", backwardation.
They'll say that the
future ... that this futures
market is in backwardation,
so backwardation and what I
want to be clear is, is that
that's what most people
are talking about, inverted
futures curve but that's not
exactly right if you we want
to give the precise academic
definition. The precise
definition is not just an
inverted curve, the precise
definition is and this is
actually the theory of normal
backwardation. It came from
Keynes and that is, is that
the sellers are willing to sell
in the future at a discount
to the expected price because
of the volatility, so that
they could lock in their
price. So the theory of normal
backwardation is actually
this phenomenon right here.
But this is actually not
observable because you can't go
and survey everyone
and figure out what the
actual expected price is
and you can see that they're
often one and the same. The
expectant price was here.
You had an inverted futures
curve. That's why they called
this curve that or this
market in backwardation.
The one way that you can
kind of observe it, is if you
see, so over here, this is our
spot price. This is our spot
price and now we're moving
over time and you can see
the spot price isn't changing
much and because it's not
changing much, this cheaper
futures price, as we move
closer and closer to its
delivery date, it has to
converge with the spot price.
As this one right over here
it starts at $75, as you go
further and further in time,
it has to converge to the
spot price and so when you see
the futures price moving
up towards the spot price,
over as it gets closer and
closer to its delivery date,
that's maybe the most
observable way that you could
say that the market is
experiencing ... is experiencing
backwardation.